BENCH. LAKERS. WITH THE BALL,
UTAH DOWN THEIR BENCHES 2 OUT
OF 12 FROM BEYOND THE ARC.
>> ZINNI TECHNICAL FOR
TAUNTING WITH I MEAN, HE
LOOKED BACK AND RUDY GOBERT.
AND THEY HAD SOME SOME WORD
THAT WAS. THAT'S WHAT REST
BEEN KNOWN FOR DOING, THOUGH,
GETTING INTO THE PAINT AND
THEN EXPLODING. DID HE EVER
EXPLODE OVER THE TOP OF
GOBERT? OH, WOW. THAT'S JUST.
MONSTER DUNK. BY RUSSELL
WESTBROOK. THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE ARE YOU I'LL LIVE WITH
THAT TECHNICAL. THAT WAS
MONSTER TYPE THAT HAS. LIFT
THIS CROWD UP. WOW. AND THAT
WAS A TRAMPOLINE ACT. THERE.
WEST BROM. AND THIS IS WHAT
WE'VE SEEN HIS ENTIRE CAREER.
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT.
>> EVERYTHING IS PREDICATED ON
HIS EXPLOSIVENESS TO THE RIM.
IT'S BEEN A FRUSTRATING YEAR.
HE'S TAKING A TON